moore
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce qui devait arriver sur un site web ou
dans le journal d'être heurté par deux
images qui s'entrechoquent
d'un côté une nourriture trop abondante
à quoi peut s'ajouter une alimentation
mal équilibrée des petits repas entre
les repas
résultat le baise personnes indique
l'excès et des régimes vont s'efforcer
de brûler c'est calories en excès des
régimes parfois fort coûteux trop de
calories d'un forment le corps fatigué
les articulations use le coeur peuvent
provoquer des maladies potentiellement
mortelles et de l'autre côté c'est un
manque de calories qui va provoquer
finalement la mort d'hommes de femmes
d'enfants au terme d'un long parcours de
souffrance que peut-on faire
cette question déjà me préoccupait
lorsque je travaillais comme médecin
dans différents hôpitaux
et puis combien d années plus tard je
suis devenu pasteur
je me suis demandé mais que faire et
alors regarder de plus près des chiffres
qui parlent d'eux mêmes
chaque
et selon des données récentes
mais il s'agit bien sûr d'une estimation
il y a environ 36 millions de personnes
qui meurent par manque de calories et
pendant une année également 29 millions
de personnes vont décéder des
conséquences des excès alimentaires la
situation paradoxale elle est
scandaleuse
que peut-on faire
ce qui a été tenté par les uns c'était
de diminuer les excès une nourriture
plus raisonnable une chasse au
gaspillage
ceux qui étaient tentés de l'autre côté
c'était de se courir les plus démunis de
faire des donations ce que vous est
proposé ici c'est une démarche qui joint
excès et manque et qui vise à diminuer
les excès corrigé tant que faire se peut
les manques pour arriver à une situation
d'équilibré où tout le monde est gagnant
offrez des calories pour la vie lutter
contre la faim et portez vous mieux
sauver des vies sans devoir sortir un
franc de plus que d'ordinaire
concrètement il s'agit de renoncer à un
repas par semaine de préférence un repas
du soir et d'offrir la contre valeur
c'est-à-dire l'argent ainsi économisé à
une oeuvre de votre choix qui vous tient
à coeur et qui lutte efficacement contre
la faim la simple idée de devoir
renoncer un repas se limité peut donner
un sentiment un peu pénible mais il est
vrai aussi que lorsqu'on offre un cadeau
à quelqu'un on ce sony les haies ni
frustré le cadeau fait plaisir non
seulement à celui qui le reçoit
mais également aux donateurs
concrètement le soir de la semaine où je
vais me coucher son souper de votre
creux il y a des gargouillis l'estomac
protestent les entrailles réclament
leurs dieux ont peur de manquer mais je
n'ai pas faim j'ai une envie de manger
et c'est autre chose
et quand j'ai envie de manger je pense
autrement à ceux qui ont faim et qui
enfin le lendemain les semaines
suivantes
et ceci jusqu'à ce que mort s'ensuive
[Musique]
cela
appel à l'empathie il ya un sentiment de
compassion souffrance avec avec ceux qui
sont littéralement condamné à mort et
les jours suivants et bien déjà le
lendemain bonne surprise
je n'éprouve pas une fin
particulièrement importante
je me lève avec le corps et le coeur
dispo et par la suite je deviens plus
conscients de la manière dont je me
nourris je peux éviter certains
automatismes comme dévorer le grand
paquet de chips tout entier en regardant
un match à la télé et je me libère petit
à petit de ce traquenard qui voudraient
nous faire croire que on peut compenser
les petites contrariétés frustration
inquiétudes de chaque jour par un
remplissage alimentaire excessif et puis
je suis plus conscient de la qualité de
ce que je mange mon assiette recèle de
la nourriture qui est précieuse et je
sais que ce n'est pas un dieu que ce
n'est pas automatique
de tout temps l'homme a mis toute son
énergie et toutes ses forces pour
trouver moyen de s'alimenter
jour après jour
la manière dont nous nous nourrissons
sur cette terre dit quelque chose de
notre manière de vivre ensemble
est ce que je mange seul dans mon coin
est-ce que je partage avec deux autres
c'est pour chacun une question
spirituelle pour moi qui suis chrétien
cette question se fait pressante
qu'est ce que nous faisons lorsque nous
prions dans le notre père cette demande
donne nous aujourd'hui notre pain de ce
jour c'est quand même autre chose que
donne mon petit pain chaque jour il ya
cette dimension communautaire
cette demande qui est faite que lle de
nourriture pour tous les enfants de la
famille du père mais si nous pensons que
dieu comptent sur nous pour pourvoir à
tous les besoins les uns des autres
ne risquons nous pas d'être écrasés
devant l'étendue des besoins pour moi je
mets ma confiance en jésus christ qui à
partir du petit peu tes données
librement et joyeusement peut faire
croître et multiplier au delà de tout ce
que nous pouvons imaginer
j'aimerais encore dire ceci si en
renonçant à un repas par semaine vous
pouvez sauver de la mort de faim une
personne voir une famille qu'est ce qui
empêche de commencer tout de suite
quelle joie de pouvoir faire quelque
chose de concret indépendamment de
décision de gouvernement dit
merci de certains organismes cela dépend
de soi même cela peut être mises en
oeuvre immédiatement il y à des
personnes de toute situation sociale qui
entrent dans cette démarche en dix ans
mais quel bonheur de pouvoir faire
quelque chose de concret sans devoir
sortir un seul franc de plus que
d'habitude de son porte monnaie et il ya
des personnes de tous âges des jeunes
les personnes âgées qui me disent être
heureuse de pouvoir faire ce cadeau et
la joie intérieure qu'elle réprouve
entretien leur motivation de semaine en
semaine
c'est ce qui permet de tenir dans la
durée ils font l'expérience que ici le
bonheur des uns fait aussi le bonheur
des autres
tout à la fois diminuer les souffrances
des affamés et se sentir mieux
c'est vraiment une joie à vivre et à
faire connaître
ainsi je vous invite vous aussi à offrir
des calories pour sauver des vies y
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]